[Music]
guys when it comes to eSports 2018
pretty much had it all I mean we saw
some breathtaking plays we saw some
historic tournament runs and of course
we saw some underdog moments we'll never
forget that's why this week on top ten
we're counting down the best plays the
best moments the best stories from 2018
that can only be described in one word
hype so sit back and don't relax too
much because we're giving you the top
ten hype moments of 2018 starting our
list off at number 10 is a taste of the
tension and rawhide that eSports can
bring this series just went from a three
to a ten really quick yes it's the
unforgettable ending to Game three
between kt rolster and Invictus gaming
at the 2018 League of Legends World
Championship in the final minute of the
match the two teams engage in a
heart-attack inducing bass race that's
on victus gaming's the shy tasked with
destroying Katie's Nexus while a 4v4
took place in the opposite village Frank
hit the shy fellow Bay v KP the shine
took down the final tower while smeb
teleported to join his allies looking to
do the same dirt they're gonna be taken
down take these to marching it's a base
Rae
sighs of the blue Nexus JT's unthread
who's gonna win the shy to auto-attacks
separated kt rolster from a game four
and a ticket home what a series being
summoned in at number nine is the moment
that saw Shenron unexpectedly grace us
with an appearance during a CEO set
between go Ichi and leffen down to his
last character in a 1v3 go Ichi was on
his way to making the comeback after
taking a left and sell the loan Vegeta
managed to channel the power of the
seven dragonballs to summon the
wish-granting dragon help with feeling
he would want the ally or the extra help
because if it's touch that's gonna be
curtains for Medea smartly or no
sparking search sunshine sparking but
sounds like a graphical glitch work
debug bow how did he come back from that
he had eleven so shook Oh God pushing
back to health you saw on my mango week
she said he said Japanese he said bless
bass said [ __ ] wrong it's safe to say
that cloud nines had one heck of a year
in eSports and it's their rocket League
teams win over Team Dignitas in the our
LCS season six grand finals that comes
in at number eight on our list a year on
cloud nine
done things that no North American
workers been able to do five nights
making it there to try and take on the
two-time reigning world champ see if
they can finally break the streak of
Dignitas won a war machine to face off
against can cloud nine to it as they
often are cloud nine with the underdogs
against the two-time defending champions
but that didn't faze them one bit
running the gauntlet all the way from
losers round one
cloud9 fought tooth and nail to reset
the brand
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen cloud nine they
have got the bracket from the lower
bracket and after they did they manage
to make rocket League history double
commit their chance for cloud nine of
gimmick can get a strong shot go on for
the highlight reel shut case a chance
for gimmick but he has no boost ball
bouncing to the net and that went eight
off to the side cloud nine mounting an
assault squishy bounces to it
[Applause]
squishy
[Applause]
digs rocket League
[Applause]
the title parks back to
Amerika carpet what
there's no better time to defy
expectations than on your chosen games
biggest stage which is why problem X's
Cinderella esque run at Evo comes in at
number seven after an incredible run to
the top eight the Bison player made it
through to the grand final on winners
side where he awaited his eventual
opponent Evos defending street fighter
champion taquito
but taquito is still on the verge of
resetting this about Mexico okay
opportunity who he challenged she
challenged we reset here and evolution
2018 and Street Fighter 5 playing the
role of David to taquitos Goliath
problem X did what many consider to be
nearly impossible giving us this height
moment on the FGCs biggest stage yeah
beautiful combo is the moment for
problem and the other side trying to go
for a good block Oh still no answers for
taco too far doesn't want to commit this
engine is malformed
oh he goes in there Charl there go
through the B reversal knocks him down
oh that should be punishable
that's taken evolution 28 at number six
is the moment that one of League of
Legends best players became an
international champion hoozy is a
grizzled league veteran and arguably the
world's best ad carry but he's never
been able to translate that individuals
skill into an international trophy that
is until the midseason Invitational this
might be the best chance for orangie to
win the title on this massive winning
streak I seen an ad carry meta with
who's he performing like it's now I
never almost and boy did he put on a
show
now he's exhausted here come on stand
united fight sometimes left musica
pretty manages get another [ __ ] [ __ ]
let me will not find the toy if there's
enough damage coming out
thanks to that tear that never down easy
the male and that's huge amount of
fungus called to king size the mystic
shot orangey played their hearts out and
this time when the team needed him most
woozy delivered in the biggest way
possible super minions on the Nexus we
are back in the game and we've gone
straight to 110 RNG inside the parapet
shoot for me in town as well we're gonna
fight is gone King so deluge gorilla and
using the Pixlr the fellas are goes back
and forth this show who dies he's alive
please me chase
finishable time Shamu is on his way
[Applause]
time is it's 40 seconds of BDD it's 33
great Tina tried to cut away the inhibit
eternities the focus and now is peanut
Ragnarok to try and escape the
inevitable fill middle there goes let me
solve it caught my god
[Applause]
it is beautiful to behold the happiness
[Applause]
the world LVL spring miracle run taking
every single opponent down that China
had to offer and now the world - coming
in at number five is the moment Pangos
team solidified themselves as the
greatest roster in Rainbow six siege
despite Penta sports incredible 2017 a
loss in the Pro League semi-finals at
the end of that year two black dragons
meant that they came into the 2018
season with a cloud of uncertainty
I think shot se is widely considered to
be one of the top players in all of
Europe and going on to Penta a lot of
people are claiming that this is going
to be the greatest super team ever
formed in rainbow after getting revenge
on the Brazilians in the 2018
Invitational semi finals Penta further
prove that they have what it takes to be
the best team in the world they'll make
it to the grand final
proving the world what's it for all that
they are arguably the best team but
there's still one more opponent to go
with and against eg they did just that
in what will likely go down as one of
the most memorable Grand Finals Rainbow
six siege has ever seen but it's not
enough Kang Yuri frags and Koga finishes
off that spoke and SDK with the follow
up they see with the finisher and Evil
Geniuses will take the first round
Bobby I'm gonna need to try something
brave here because he possibly goes for
a plan bathing it out goes through the
80s neck Rock cat hitting dot at fabien
wins it how does that happen is Penghu
going to be able to cover that fire he
gets BC can pay you keep going he's
looks so good thank you with neck rocks
takes it down
any cheese dangle I don't get the
diffuser pens are not taking this just
yet none will need to get him he has
only ten seconds and he enters they will
be in a standoff can he get the Valkyrie
two seconds
young pushes up running at a time
neither get it Penza hold on oh my
Matt's point pet tuck just wait they'll
look to push together the diffuser in a
position where they'll have to see when
the Habano goes through one will cover
the doorway as they start to diffuse and
you go through one on the young getting
on a second there often known as the
best team in the world never having that
distinction until today pets are norm
world champions they have to feel elated
the most wins now of any team including
a whole world fish taking the number
four spot is cloud nines run at Worlds
throughout most of League of Legends
history South Korea has dominated the
international competition while North
America has been considered the weakest
of the five major regions but this year
cloud nine did what no NA team since
season one had done
two teams one from na and one from EU
each striking down all of their
opponents to arrive right here in this
moment against each other in the biggest
rivalry either region ever imagined na
versus EU for the last spot in the World
Championship final
at one point a tenth place team in the
summer split c9 clawed their way to
Worlds main event only to be seeded into
the group of death Wyant we knew it was
coming but when you didn't see it in the
actual graphic you're like all right
it's sinking in this is not gonna be
easy and just to make sure this should
of course be cloud nine who will get up
drawn as it was written in the stars
into the group of death with Genji
orangey and vitality but the boys in
blue once again defined expectations by
making it out in second place one toy
already out Spence Karen's got a GA is
about to lose fat this town is there keV
a shirt gets the shield 5d3 who push
continues lifts on the attempted gaol
they're gonna shut down vitality and
cloud nine pass the group of death and
qualify for the quarterfinals and it was
in the quarter-final where c9 made
history by defeating the Africa freaks
in dominant fashion to become the first
North American team to make it to Worlds
semi-finals in seven years yeah the
objective doesn't go down that route
still stands but tensions I got he wants
to shut down in a huge shadow Tuesday's
TLAs aim on that ultimate got to knock
ups out of that press and that I think
helped really allow that dive on victory
now
Saros monumental run at this year's
Blizzcon takes the number three spot on
our list since Blizzcon debut in 2005
south korea has dominated starcraft year
after year and since the introduction of
the Starcraft 2 World Championship
Series in 2013 a non-korean has never
made it to the grand final let alone won
the event but in 2018 a young zerg
player from Finland named cero was
determined to change history and boy did
he ever
number one you can see the attack
continuing to come forward he's banging
at the gates of stances second base
there is so much over here the core goes
down Kadim stats are so strong keep in
mind there is no or prism with this army
so what you see is what you get
seral continuing just around the few
remaining immortals drones now being
pulled as well the drones mean that this
is serious Cyril knows he must hold
right here right now another great storm
but only three of us left over and it
looks like Sarah will hold
damn Jeff but you can really see but
look at that every time an abduct goes
off he kills another carrier to morph
all the brood Lords starting to get
picked off here as well though he comes
in once more he can basically one-shot
these carriers and I don't think there's
any solution in four steps he's got to
commend Cheryl Walker welded the
airplane up steps and that is
I know I know at the same yeah I mean
when I came here I wasn't really a quick
thing to win but at the same time it
doesn't I go so yeah it is incredible at
the runner-up spot on our list is cloud
nines incredible run at the Boston major
for a long time it seemed that a North
American team would never achieve the
status of major champion in csgo but
cloud9 were hell-bent to keep the trophy
on home soil well we're gonna find out
what happens when the old guard runs up
against a new school they've got to take
on cloud 9 me and short of talk about we
think this is the best iteration of
going into their Grand Finals matchup
against faze clan as the underdogs
things looked rough early on the
Guardian comes back in oh god idiot -
there's still more to go though god I
must plot the bomb the peeps come in but
Guardian will not stop one more to go
and Guardian yes then Oh
but America's Heroes would not be denied
and put on a showing that will be
remembered for years to come
oh he has 30 HP he's got no grenades
he's holding a tight angle Guardian is
so red not expecting it it's good to do
this one lots of guys do fear nothing
else is going on he's on
[Applause]
it's called a coma they came back all
the way
it is a dance and now they concede
multiple ankle terrico he takes all the
prices are down Dardenne on 11 HP rained
peaks and he gets the angle now secure
angle is there a diffuse for the CT side
the non-indigent
they're spamming the grenades they're
touching the book and now go frame
another pod that is trying to choose a
gender no guardian has taken down
guardian waits patiently as cloud my
scepter push up
[Applause]
that is the most insane way so when I
made up
you just couldn't script a better story
than oh geez run at TI 8 which is why
it's the obvious choice to take the
number one spot on our list
[Applause]
going into TI OG had been completely
written off by just about everybody they
still a lot of questions around urging
yes right because like obviously he had
the roster ripped apart by evil geniuses
with a departure of Lyonesse for but no
tail and his team of fresh-faced players
defied everyone's expectations beating
out some of the tournament's best teams
[Applause]
his rivals og with the fortitude to
stick through it and persevering through
seemingly unwinnable death he gets that
fight with the stove will say taking the
bad shot soldiers will be able to find
the other but then fully load UD that
suckers never two minutes they get
Thompson total never to be so Dianna
Anna can you do it head
of his lifetime the moment that og
lifted the aegis of champions is one
that eSports fans across the world won't
soon forget
[Applause]
friendship
you're glad champions
okay guys so that was our top ten height
moments from 2018 now after watching all
those incredible clips I am hype AF and
if you want to get rid of that energy
hit the like button hit the sub button
comment below and I'll see you next week
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]